NAEP is called The Nation's Report Card
because these test scores consistently
measure student learning over time. 2019's results were just released, and
warrant three takeaways and a caution. First,
results were grim. Math scores were up a
tick in fourth grade, but they dropped in
eighth grade, and both grades dropped in
reading. Indeed, eighth grade reading
scores changed more than at any time in
that test's history, and in the wrong
direction. Second, these declines look
worse against the backdrop of the past
decade. While NAEP scores mostly climbed
from 1990 through 2010, performance
stagnated since, and 2015 saw widespread
declines for the first time — until now.
Third, declines were driven by our lowest
scoring students, and since high
performing students stayed flat, the gap
between them is growing. A caution: After
this lousy report card, expect to see a
number of articles offering pet
explanations for the poor showing. Truth
is, there are simply too many factors
involved to know exactly why scores
declined, but even if they can't pinpoint
a cause, these results are a sobering
reminder of where our students are.
Are you more concerned with the declines on
NAEP, or on the growing divide between
low- and high-performing students? Let us
know in our poll. Also, let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds, and be sure to like
and subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI.